communauté jugent que ben ils sont
préparés y ont des plaintes pour
répondre au feu ils savent qu'ils vivent
dans des environnements où c'est plus
propice susceptible d'arriver
soyons des expériences passées aussi de
feu qui sont venus proches ou de gestion
des forêts avec le feu donc pour eux ils
y ont des connaissances de combattre le
feu il décide de rester pour essayer de
combattre puis de préserver leurs
communautés là parce que c'est quand
même être celle aussi de juste partie
puis d'abandonner de laisser le combat
juste aux autres donc c'est quelque
chose qu'on voit que l'on botanique
présentement mais qui dans d'autres
communautés puis qui absorbe aussi
landau pays
les chercheurs ont des collaborations
avec des gens de l'australie puis entre
autres parce que oui a dit cette soirée
là bas oui et en soins des feux de
forêts qui l'ont aussi avec beaucoup de
gens qui voulaient rester on peut parler
dans les communautés autochtones mais
souvent pour les fermiers les gens dans
en milieu rural
c'est important qu'ils sont habitués au
cid s'organiser par eux-mêmes souvent
donc pour eux c'est une chose de plus
qui voit qu'ils sont capables de
défendre leur terre impie leur leurs
biens dont ils y ont des idées
politiques pour aider un peu la facilité
ce puits à responsabiliser les gens
parce que il faut se préparer quand même
si on a l'intention de faire ce qu'est
ce qui est fait jusqu'à maintenant parce
que je pense vous ai parlé d'une
collègue qui travaille un site web
s'appelle first nations world fire huit
communautés qui sont étudiées pour les
partenariats d'évacuation est ce qu on a
déjà une idée de la façon de fonctionner
peut-être avec les communautés
autochtones qui est différente avec les
communautés qui ne sont pas toc tonnes
oui ben on se rend compte de ce que les
chercheurs ont constaté avec un ont fait
des centaines d'entrevues et des besoins
qui sont rendus à la rentrante à la
démographie des communautés autochtones
qui sont des familles plus l'ombre vivre
des familles élargies souvent dans le
même domicile donc des choses aussi
simples que des turcs ont assez de
véhicules pour évacuer toute une famille
parce que ses rangs que tout le monde
est petit voyage en même temps des
familles élargies avec les grands
parents
puis des questions aussi de gestion
d'avoir assez d'essence pour tout le
monde parce que ça aussi
habituellement je peux tout le monde une
grande partie de la population qui
parlent en même temps tu vas avoir
plusieurs genres de retaper